we're here to talk about the only game
that anyone cares about right now if you
go on any video game website hell if you
go turn your television on if you walk
outside if you walk if you walk out your
window yes right now there are hordes of
teens walking around with their phones
ABS I'm just not Justine Justine
grown-ass adults me included the Polka
mangos and it goes it goes and it goes
look let's let's be honest here right
everyone's covering this game too much
it's a constant source of traffic for us
it is doing all the articles doing loads
of page views the videos are doing load
so I was like we're gonna have to talk
about Pokemon just nothing else to talk
about we have talked about Pokemon go so
at the very least we can have a funny
wrap-up of all the stupidest news
stories that are about Pokemon go it's
alright son okay Saturday's alright we
go to knit sir ok all right ok no more
down votes ok that's it so first I got a
couple of stories here okay and I want
to basically gauge your guys's a
painting on this the first one man quits
job in order to catch all the pokemon
okay this is a coming out of our hot
scoops over at mashable com and this is
a gentleman who worked as a barista
somewhere in New Zealand and he is
basically quit his job so he can
Instagram take photographs of every
single Pokemon old how many is 150 in
Pokemon go 15 to 50 slots 150 in total
right I'll see there's like groups of
people over the slots but yeah this is
just the original because I've just got
250 zoo bots right now so I most people
okay what do you think about quitting
your job to catch all the pokemon pita
bread I mean maybe it's just what this
guy needs to live a happy fulfilling
life I don't know just sick of making
coffees not for me ya know I couldn't do
it I couldn't do I pardon me things like
strike two months from now he's gonna be
like man two months reading the hell is
I think I think he's gone I don't know
how long does it take to catch all under
50 catch and evolve rather do you think
it'll do you think he'll get to the end
of the two feet don't I'm not gonna I
need the regret what calm I'm not gonna
doubt his commitment to his charge okay
once he reaches it then what
I mean I like the idea that he's going
to be fully committed until he'd reaches
it that's amazing it's gonna be like
that moment when Forrest Gump runs all
the way to the west coast right and then
gets in he's like Oh better run back
there are pictures of him here with I
don't know what [ __ ] what is that if
some sort of pony OC is he is he dressed
waste rally I use just take no he's not
dressed like a she's just hanging out
with this thing then his ass mittman
isn't is that's true it's good for it
it's a picture of him at the border
power bank a Christchurch I think this
guy must just love these got four
thousand followers is it a lot no I
don't know he's got a facebook you gonna
hang out with him on facebook go to
facebook com for it / tom bleah be and
Zed ple be not sure if that's a surname
where things happen in New Zealand ok
next story that would that's did there
there's all this pictures look at that
look at a hot Instagram content look at
that dang don't get those views making
coffee hey fair play to him he could
definitely drop Pokemon in espresso
phone ha that's pretty good actually we
should probably comment on us then ok
next one this is a video I'm not sure if
the guys in the back have this cute up
this is uh I'm gonna call it I'm gonna
go ahead and say it man falls into pond
playing pokemon go yeah this is somebody
who was at twitch streaming their
Pokemon go play which I just wanted was
a twitch plays my pokemon go or
something and it's just me made in water
yeah this is Otto but if you say so this
is him at night I'm just walking along
collecting some pokemon and then
suddenly it goes dark and you hear the
sound of water it's it's a career I like
to the point where it sounds like his
microphone it's just like totally not
there we go nice gone there you go
obvious mistake there that he wasn't
playing an AR mode the right thing could
have been with I didn't see in the
darkness that's gotta that's gotta suck
jumping I live beside a lake and
literally the whole thing I walk around
us all the time me my partner dear like
probably like three times a week maybe
the whole thing just likes random groups
of people like dropping lowers just
start putting
yeah they won't know just because
they're so into their phone right right
that could be my twitch stream just go
ahead pushing other people I'm Instagram
I'll just do it like I'll make sure i'm
eating a doughnut so it's part of
twitches like eating oh right right
right yeah it's great social easily done
socially eating a doughnut holding I
guess your phone and then walking around
how would you push me just like oh while
talking about league of legends don't
look at me like that's not the future
games Jake okay next one local
businesses dropping lures how do we feel
about this Radio Shack had a twenty-five
percent off power banks if you catch a
Pokemon nothing's gonna say British a
cancer you don't like radio shack no
they went bankrupt like two years ago oh
really ninety percent of their stores
they're hanging on by a thread okay well
so they gotta you gotta do there's a
there's a cafe right down the block
that's got like a little chalkboard
pokemon on it okay talking about come
here two to 230 we're dropping lures
like crazy like beside the other I get
ten percent off i mean i think for
businesses it's a it's a real smart move
but certain brands or maybe just types
of businesses played more to that
demographic like radio shack right or
coffee or hillary clinton cuz i guess
she's drying laura's to for her yeah yet
to get so to come to her stuff Mike and
I ubered here and the uber driver told
us all about like people he's driven
around like catch pokemon like to the
middle of nowhere he told us about how
Hillary Clinton I guess is dropping
lures so she can i mean i don't know
like she's writing her monetize teens I
guess but like I don't know it seems to
be a good I don't know not a bad way to
get people to go to your rally she sees
one of the ashes hats to wear directly
write out some catch pokemon did you see
the UFC guy as a little bit of an aside
the UFC fight wasn't UFC saw it was
Bellator Ithaca was the fighter who know
he like rolled a ball he kneeled him
yeah and then he like threw he picked
out his gum shield rolled it towards him
after he like basically teak out and and
then like put the cap on I like that oh
my god the most messed up part i sorries
if that guy like as literally fractured
his skull open well then he's a spittle
right now Joe
yes there's likes it sits cyborgs ex was
a whose EFC fighter now she's one of the
head wealth white women's division
fighters and it's her husband and his is
a picture of him hospital in the UK and
he literally is like a like it looks
like his head just got like punched it's
so bad so this guy was like literally
holding his face kulbir together and the
guy was like doing up to trolling him
like ash ketchum yeah it is you guy who
I almost killed and that's pretty [ __ ]
up what do you think about the mcdonalds
thing have you heard about this sir
pioneer editor is like busted open the
code and fetish like McDonald's are the
first like Oh sponsored shinning yeah so
all mcdonalds are gonna be I think Jim's
sure it's a logical conclusion I mean
it's that's where the money is yeah no
problem you don't care for all the
players no I mean what I'm gonna people
are going to mcdonalds if they want what
if there's a mamas and papas burger
joint across the road to which was a gym
they're like oh no we can't you be a gym
anymore we're gonna give it to Ronald
over here I suppose that's true but
would you things like that I think that
Dixon burger selling I think like the
bigger problem though is that all this
walking they're doing is for nothing now
that they just go to make McDonald's
it's good point as long as you don't
have to like eat at McDonald's or like
go like there's no restrictions like
that and like whatever who cares hey
phones in that bad no I a McDonald's but
I'm saying if you try to drum up any
sort of like well because this
controversial oh right that would be the
only thing that could like if you had
via you got like a free side up if you
bought a hamburger so my god yeah cuz
I'd be buying hamburgers or sex I oh
yeah fine last one here set it and on a
real funny one probably loads no egg get
out of this now man stabbed all playing
pokemon go keeps playing this is a this
is this is a beautiful story and because
mostly of the the lines you can see the
yeah hi very well highlighted there I
basically rest my life he said I have a
line here and mr. Baker his first name
I'll come up here michael Baker 21 was
catching pokemon characters in Forest
Grove all right in one am what I am
monday when i am on a monday nothing
ever happens when he saw another man
walking in the area and approached him
apparently Michael approached the other
man and I saw a guy go I saw him go by
and asked if he was playing pokemon go
he was like was stabbed would you say to
me did you call me a Pokemon a thousand
person today I can't take it I guess he
wanted to battle because he came up at
me with a knife Baker told him ah yeah
right after I was stabbed I continue
with my mission to played pantry for my
mission for chips and beer Baker said so
he just got caught on the hand as we say
that bad day but he like they had to
call the cops and he wouldn't he didn't
want to cuz he wanted to catch pokemon
did he get some stitches to sew it was
like kind of bad right i thought i read
he got like eight stitches or so yeah
but button oh yeah but he wanted to be
the very best i guess i feel like this
is just like a college kid who's like
hey let's set this up like it's his
friend a dress up like a ride yeah just
like any good so i won't like the news
for shine and his friend like like like
it's like that tragic tale worried like
to stab him like too much or yeah they
scream yeah exactly I knew I was pulling
this from somewhere thank you Peter
you're welcome the ending of scream just
how TV show oh yeah are you are you okay
man you stabbed me too what does he say
like you give me the stomach did he ever
get the beer and chips though yeah he
did he did okay Olivia and then he went
on his merry way and now he's imagine
doing that first of all and then imagine
like like saying okay to the television
interview of you being that much of a
pleb yeah like just being like yeah I'm
gonna own this I love Pokemon so much I
almost [ __ ] died imagine quitting
your job to Victor small speakers it's
true imagine falling into a lake just a
handful of the stories we have on this
week's Pokemon go we can [ __ ] top story
rag on show out of it yeah check back
next week on the lobby to find out which
ways humanity is embarrassing itself
through the medium of Pokemon go okay
let's get on to more pressing
where were these stories when own
ingress was out where are those tragic
English incidents the english ones are
where i was listening to the podcast
this week and Jeff was talking about how
apparently they used to like people
would put up walls like put up like like
debris so people couldn't get two
different ingress points like they were
like super territorial around us not
good I'd never even heard of ingress
until I be heard of ingress for not
until Pokemon go right thing yeah it's
like I don't know yeah this loads of
geocaches where I live though I so I
ogio dudes I wait Trader Joe's car park
is full of goddamn zoo box they're like
everywhere